[Musique]
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
frédéric péchenard bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vice-président
de la région ile-de-france ancien
directeur général de la police nationale
et ça tombe bien au moment où on parle
du bureau de la sécurité on va bien sûr
en parler avec vous on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par florent buisson
de la république du centre bourg
florence bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin on commence par la
crise sanitaire
frédéric péchenard et de gouvernement
qui temporise avant de prendre la
décision d'un long confinement ou du
moins de l'annoncé on ne sait pas
vous voyez j'imagine comme nous ces
manifestations parfois violentes
notamment aux pays bas avec des
protestations contre les mesures de
restriction est ce que vous pensez que
ce type d'événement peut arriver en
france est ce que vous pensez qu'il y
aura une acceptabilité des français sur
ce 3ème confinement s'il arrive ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que les français ont
quand même très bien réagi face à cette
pandémie
puisque finalement ça fait maintenant
pratiquement un an qu'on est extrêmement
contraint dans une activité à la fois
personnelle et professionnelle on peut
plus voyager ou très difficilement et je
trouve que les français ont fait preuve
de beaucoup de discipline mais on voit
bien que petit à petit bien sur
l'acceptabilité s'érode et il est pas du
tout impossible qu'on ait des scènes
s'il y avait un nouveau confinement et
qu'on voit des scènes en france comme
celles qu'on peut voir ailleurs d'autant
plus que finalement on avait mis
beaucoup d'espoir dans le vaccin
et on voit bien que cet espoir est bien
il s'amenuise en tout cas ils
s'éloignent est-ce que ce confinement
vous le
souhaitez vous le craignez vous dites on
n'a pas d'autre solution vous dites il
faut tout faire pour l'éviter
je suis pas du tout un spécialiste des
épidémies et j'ai tendance à me conduire
comme de façon raisonnable
j'ai envie de dire comme un comme un bon
français donc à partir du moment où vous
voyez bien les conseiller dans les halls
torino mis à la sécurité et politiques
prennent des décisions j'ai toujours
tendance à croire qu'elles qu'elles sont
bonnes bon ce qu'il faut éviter quand
même c'est cette impression
un jour oui un jour non un jour j'y vais
un jour j'y vais pas je crois qu'on a
besoin d'un cap ce cap tout le monde
peut le comprendre là finalement on est
passé il ya peu de temps en temps un
couvre-feu de 18h qui finalement sera
pas forcément extrêmement différent d'un
confinement où on pourra continuer à
travailler
on voit bien que les sujets ils sont pas
ils sont pas vraiment là je crois qu'il
faut surtout arrêter de faire des
allers-retours permanents
même si j'ai bien compris qu'il fallait
s'adapter l épidémie
donc il faut tracer un cap sur plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois où ils vous je
crois qu'on a besoin de sens de l'accord
jusqu'à l'été jusqu'à la sortie de la
crise on a besoin de quelqu'un a besoin
d'un cap on a besoin qu'on nous dise
voilà voilà ce qu'il va se passer
et surtout on a besoin de croire à la
parole publique et ça c'est pas du
moment où il ya eu quand même beaucoup
de difficultés beaucoup de
contre-vérités qui ont pu est dit sur
les masques sur les vaccins maintenant
eh bien c'est vrai que quand maintenant
vous avez des politiques qui s'expriment
nous avons un doute sur ce qui peut être
la réalité alors bob est encore très
longtemps il ya un ministre qui a dit
que elles étaient 70 millions de
français sont vaccinés il ya le
responsable du conseil scientifique ni
jamais de la vie ce sera 15 millions on
va bientôt qu entre 15 millions et 67
millions il ya quand même un delta qui
est extrêmement important du coup tous
sacrés du trouble et je pense qu' il
faudrait qui est peut-être moins de gens
qui s'expriment et en réfléchissant un
peu mieux jean rtement sur sur les
vaccins vous parler de problèmes de
méthode et souhaité que s'agissant de la
logistique ce soit le ministère de
l'intérieur qui s'en charge
qu'est ce que cela changerait
concrètement en termes d'efficacité sur
le terrain vraiment je crois que il ya
une erreur
stratégique qui est fait qui est de
confier une crise quelles qu'elles
soient
un ministère qui n'est pas préparé pour
ça le mystère et la santé n'est pas
préparé pour la gestion des crises c'est
pas vrai on voit bien les ars ils rament
quand même un petit peu si vous me
permettez cette expression il ya deux
ministères en france qui sont capables
de gérer des crises et le mystère de
défense notamment pour les crises
extérieures et ministère de l'intérieur
pour les crises qu'est ce que cette nuit
ses intérieurs d'abord ce sens du préfet
donc vous avez les représentants du
gouvernement qui représente tous les
ministres qui sont présents dans tous
les départements de france et les
sous-préfets dans toutes les sous
préfectures
j'ai fait il ya un maillage territorial
très fort avec un chef kelmiz de
l'intérieur et puis sous les ordres des
préfets vous avez la police la
gendarmerie les pompiers
certes les moyens à la fois humain et
technique de faire de la logistique
parce que finalement cette crise c'est
une crise sanitaire on l'a bien compris
mais par exemple pour les vaccinations
pour les masquer ce n'est pas après mme
sanitaires on n'a pas besoin pour
acheminer les vaccins ou pour acheter
des masques on n'a pas besoin d'avoir un
médecin ou un conseiller scientifique
par contre on a besoin d'une chaîne
logistique qui seraient mobilisés dans
ce cas là les policiers eux mêmes les
préfets et sous l'autorité des préfets
la totalité des services de l'état avec
évidemment en première ligne la police
la gendarmerie les pompiers
le sujet par exemple du vaccin ils ont
le temps aujourd'hui de faire ça les
policiers les gendarmes et les pompiers
ça tout dépend c'est toujours pareil
c'est une question de mission quelle
mission veut assigner aux forces de
l'ordre
si on considère que la crise sanitaire
c'est la priorité
ce que je pense aujourd'hui 1
malheureusement cette crise elle masque
la crise économique et crise sociale la
crise sécuritaire que nous verrons après
mais pour l'instant faut faire les
choses comme elles viennent dans l'ordre
où elles viennent pour l'instant un cri
sanitaire c'est la priorité
alors oui je pense qu'il faut affecter
le maximum de gens le sujet c'est pas de
créer le vaccin existe c'est pas de le
fabriquer malheureusement c'est pas nous
français qu'ils fabriquent ont donc
c'est comment on fait d'abord pour en
avoir plus ça c'est un problème qui est
diplomatique et politique
incontestablement on voit bien que ben
on a pas on en a pas assez
on n'a pas tout ce qu'on voulait
visiblement alors qu'il ya d'autres pays
qui s'en sont mieux tirés que nous et
puis ensuite une fois qu'on a les
vaccins le sujet c'est de les prendre à
la sortie de l'usiné qui les fabriquent
et les emmener jusqu'aux centres de
vaccination pour qu'il ya un mais
qu'ils mettent dans le bras des gens on
voit bien que ce n'est pas un problème
logistique
alors c'est déjà c'est bien sûr c'était
énorme surtout que la logistique des
vaccins est compliqué il faut les garder
au moins 80 etc
mais je pense que fondamentalement ça
doit être au mr l'intérieur de gérer ces
crises et qu'elle serait
incontestablement mieux gérer ses thèmes
et ses intérieurs qu'avait pris le lead
justement vous qui êtes vice-président
de la région comment ça se passe
désormais la campagne vaccinale dans une
de france est ce que ça se passe mieux
est ce que les choses s'améliorent non
ça se passe pas bien ça se passe pas
bien parce que alors une fois de plus
les leurs je suis pas là pour donner des
leçons et pour donner des satisfecits
je fais un constat le constat c'est que
nous avions mis quand je dis nous nous
les français nous les élus locaux nous
avions mis beaucoup d'espoir dans le
vaccin et nous espérions comme d'aller
se sortir de cette crise grâce aux
vaccins nous l'espérons d'ailleurs
toujours ce qui fait que dès que les
vaccins sont arrivés et bien
immédiatement les maires les régions se
sont mis en ordre de bataille sous
l'autorité de l'état pour ouvrir cet
entre deux centres de vaccination c'est
à dire que par exemple moi je suis un
élu du xviie arrondissement le maire
geoffroy boulard a créé mais avec enfin
pas son propre sa propre initiative
comme j'ai entendu dire c'est parce
qu'on lui a donné le feu vert
deux centres de vaccination dans les
locaux de sos médecins et un à la mairie
du 17e alors créé un centre de
vaccination ça veut dire des locaux ça
veut dire du matériel ça veut surtout
dire des médecins donc on a eu des
partenariats avec les médecins
la seule chose qu'on n'a pas si j'ose
dire c'est le vaccin puisqu'on ne peut
pas acheter directement vaccin donc
c'était près et puis on devait ouvrir le
premier le 18 le deuxième le 25 le 20 et
le 22 août nous ali ben on suit 25 v
déjà des gens qui avaient pris des
rendez vous donc évidemment ça génère de
la frustration ça génère de l'inquiétude
c'est génère de la pénurie
voilà donc ça c'est ça va pas ça c'est
un truc qui va pas du tout des exemples
comme ça j'en ai énormément
un de mes collaborateurs dont la soeur
et aides soignants dans un ehpad elle a
fait sa garde de nuit
elle avait un rendez vous au petit matin
pour se faire vacciner est arrivé on y
lit pas d'accent le maire de
l'haÿ-les-roses vincent jean brun avec
qui je siégeais au conseil régional la
semaine dernière me disait ben moi on
m'a dit tu auras mille doses à première
semaine j'ai donc ouvert pour 1000
personnes et quand le lundi matin je
suis allé chercher parce qu'on va
chercher les vaccins au dernier moment
si au début il y avait 250 voilà
donc tout ça crée une sensation
d'impréparation de faiblesse de l'état
qui est qui est très préjudiciable
en tout cas si les responsables de
salles et à les commandes est repassée
par l'union européenne qui ne reçoit pas
suffisamment de doses des labos je fais
ça tu as dans les négociations je je
constate je pense tu as deux choses je
pense à deux premières manches il est
des pays qui s'en tire mieux que nous
donc pour lui ce nom les états unis
l'angleterre israël ont déjà avec ciné
énormément de personnes qui visiblement
n'ont pas tout à fait les mêmes
problèmes que nous au sein de l'union
européenne nous avons fait le choix de
commencer doucement ce qui là aussi me
paraît être une des curieuses je vois
bien pourquoi ça a été fait c'était pour
rassurer des anti vaccins mais ça n'a
pas de sens il fallait au contraire
vacciner le plus vite possible parce qu
il faut sauver des vies même si on en a
qu'un million de doses et ben on va
sauver 500 mais personne autant les
sauver le plus vite possible
et puis une fois que les premiers sont
vaccinés toute manière moi je pense
qu'il faut d'abord parler à ceux qui
veulent le vaccin et puis après assez
naturellement ceux qui sont un petit peu
inquiets ils viendront pas ce qu'ils
verront bien que plus à personne
vaccinée et moyens d'effets secondaires
et bien plus ça donne confiance
on va parler des questions de sécurité
que vous connaissez bien évidemment
frédéric péchenard et gérald darmanin
qui a donc donné lundi le coup d'envoi
du beauvau de la sécurité alors c'est
ainsi que de consultation ça va durer
jusqu'au mois de mai y aura même une
trentaine de déplacement du ministre de
l'intérieur c'est ce qu'il a annoncé
l'objectif c'est de donner plus de
moyens aux forces de l'ordre et de
renforcer le lien entre la police et la
population est ce que vous dites ce bobo
de la sécurité c'est la bonne méthode
c'est utile c'est c'est sûrement
utiliser obligé de faire un constat
quand même c'est là que le sait même
question s'est posée il ya un an et demi
et le ministre de l'intérieur de
l'époque avait décidé de faire un livre
blanc de sécurité mais que jackass tabou
ces questions étaient bien sûr abordés
donc il ya eu ça a duré un an et demi je
crois enfin il ya eu au moins
de discussions les syndicats ont été
entendus à se rendre d'experts de
professionnels de sécurité
moi j'étais pas j'avais pas été conviée
sinon j'y serais allé bien là volontiers
et puis au bout d'un an j'ai vu un
changement de gouvernement gérera
darmanin a repris le ministère de
l'intérieur il s'est donné le temps de
lire le livre blanc il a il la fait
partager
début septembre il a pris un stand de
décisions en fonction de ses réflexions
du livre blanc et notamment de lier des
expérimentations qui devait commencer je
sais pas ça a été fait d'ailleurs au 1er
janvier
et tout d'un coup le président de la
république dit bobo tout ce qui a été
fait c'est pour rire on recommence alors
que de deux choses l'une où le travail
sur le livre blanc a été extrêmement
moyen voire médiocre et donc on a décidé
de tourner la page et de leur faire
autre chose je vois pas pourquoi
ou alors c'est un petit peu
superfétatoire alors voyons pas nouveau
ça les choses sont simples c'est quelle
mission veut pour la police et la
gendarmerie et en fonction de ses
missions quels moyens on va leur donner
voilà c'est ça c'est l'essentiel après
le reste c'est quand même relativement
cosmétiques même si dans le
rapprochement police population
il ya des choses extrêmement importantes
à faire moi je vois deux axes et vous me
permettez rapidement le premier axe et
la communication
je trouve que la police communique mal
j'ai été 30 ans dans la police
j'ai toujours trouvé que la police même
quand vous la dirigez une idée mal oui
oui j'ai pourtant fait ce que je pouvais
pour mieux communiquer mais j'ai truc on
a toujours du mal
les policiers estiment que
fondamentalement parce que parce qu'on
est comme ça parce que la loi aussi
comme ça nous pousse à ça dans les
écoles de police et que la communication
ne fait pas partie de notre métier
or oui elle fait partie de notre métier
on voit bien que il faut qu'on
communique plus qu'on communique mieux
systématiquement sur tout ça je crois
que ça renforcera ce que c'est aussi la
méfiance concerne une partie de la
population envers la police qui crée
aussi c'est ce qu'on dit à cette lacune
non non je crois je crois que la
défiance elle existe dans une partie de
la population
mais vous savez c'est ce que je dis
toujours je suis rappelé en 1981 de 1980
jusqu'au mois de janvier là chaque année
il ya deux ou trois sondages par an les
policiers les gendarmes sont toujours
parmi les professions les plus
plébiscités en france et en qui les
français ont plus confiance je crois que
de mémoire le plus mauvais score ses 66%
le meilleur c'est 89
si vous prenez les journalistes ou les
hommes politiques on est à moins de 30
donc on voit bien que la confiance elle
existe le respect et l'efficacité il est
là mais je crois vraiment qu'on voudrait
mieux communiquer et puis il ya une
autre chose j'ai vu que gérald darmanin
le proposait je l'avais proposé aussi
d'ailleurs dans mon récemment dans le
dernier livre que j'avais écrit et
j'avais essayé de mettre en place quand
j'étais directeur général de la police
nationale c'est une vraie réserve
opérationnelle aujourd'hui la réserve de
la police ce ne sont que d'anciens
policiers
donc vous avez d'abord il va pas
beaucoup et en plus par définition ils
ont plus de 55 ans donc vous leur faites
pas fait n'importe quoi et j'ai vu la
réserve de l'armée française vous avez
des jeunes français qui s'engage qui
sont formés qui donnent de leur temps
qu'ils sont rémunérés un petit peu bien
sûr en contrepartie mai
qui font finalement l'honneur de l'armée
française
et ça rapproche il joue également
labellisé la population je voudrais
qu'on est exactement la même chose pour
la police c'est laid je donne des cours
à sciences po et l'année dernière dans
monkey le métier de conférence il y
avait un réserviste de l'armée de terre
il aide avant un réserviste de la
gendarmerie
et bien cette personne est un vecteur
d'influencé auprès de ses petits
camarades il sait très bien voilà ce que
je fais ils en parlent ça plaît c est ce
que c'était dans d'autres milieux que
celui de sciences po par exemple qu'il
faut aller chercher les bien sûr il faut
les chercheurs il faut chercher des
jeunes je pense faut chercher des jeunes
qui sont pour certains en échec scolaire
ça peut leur donner une possibilité
d'ailleurs une envie de rentrer dans la
police savait le l'ascenseur social et
il existe très fortement dans la police
puisque vous pouvez commencer l'adjoint
de sécurité sans le bac sans rien en
échec scolaire et finir commissaire
divisionnaire fin des exemptions a
énormément comme ça donc si on si on
accès sur une meilleure communication
d'une part et sur le réussir à trouver
30 40 mille jeunes français de tous les
milieux de qui viennent de partout et
qui s'intègre à la police puis ré un
échange permanent
je trouve que ça serait certainement
intéressant gérald darmanin a fait une
autre proposition dans le cadre de ce
bourreau de la sécurité c'est d'ouvrir
donc là davantage la police en proposant
dix mille stages et contrats
d'apprentissage aux jeunes des quartiers
prioritaires principalement qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
je pense que je sais pas c'est pas une
mauvaise idée mais vous savez des
adjoints de sécurité qui sont quand même
assez nombreux dans la police nous
allons sécurité c'est des gens qui n'ont
pas le bac qui donc pas se présenter un
concours pour entrer dans la police
garde la paix officiers vous commissaire
et qui viennent passer deux fois trois
ans au maximum
donc ils peuvent passer six ans à faire
à peu près le même travail que les
gardiens de la paix et ils ont des
facilités des possibilités de passer un
concours interne sans diplôme pour
devenir garde la tête
la moitié de la paix aujourd'hui
proviennent des avions sécurité quant
aux autres adjoints de sécurité
ceux qui ne réussissent pas le concours
d'un comme ils ont une expérience de la
sécurité ils peuvent aller faire la
sécurité dans le privé
intégrer une police municipale etc etc
et là on va quand même chercher des gens
qui sont en échec dont un certain nombre
sont dans les quartiers et ça nous
permet d'avoir la police elle ressemble
à la population main ni plus ni moins
faut pas croire que les policiers y sont
ils sont issus de la population
française comme les gendarmes comme les
militaires un mot sur un autre sujet
c'est le passage à tabac du jeune mûri
oui vous disiez je crois qu'un passage à
tabac de ce type y en a je cite tous les
jours en ile de france qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire a justement pour ça cesse
alors bien sûr il ya des jeux je crois
que cette affaire est de temps en temps
une affaire on sait pas toujours
pourquoi d'ailleurs d'un coup les médias
se focalisent dessus ce qu'elle est
choquante peut-être on en parle
énormément bien sûr mais des choses
choquantes ya les vidéos qui tournent
tout le temps alors là il ya une vidéo
il ya le fait que ça se passe dans un
quartier calme qu est le 15e
arrondissement de paris à l'intérieur de
paris
donc c'est vrai qu' on est plus habitué
à voir ces choses là où dans d'autres
dans d'autres quartiers
mais ces violences elles existent elles
existent moi je suis relativement
inquiet parce que je constate c'est une
augmentation progressive de la violence
j'ai toujours pensé qu'on était dans un
pays qui était de moins en moins violent
on n'a malheureusement pas le temps d'en
parler très longuement mais juste eu une
une chose il ya deux fois moins
d'homicides il ya eu deux fois moins
d'homicides en france entre 1990 et 2012
or un pays où il ya deux fois moins de
by side où on se situe donc deux fois
moins sûr sur 20 ans c'est pas un pays
qui est plus gênant
malheureusement le nombre des homicides
est reparti à la hausse depuis 2014
systématiquement chaque année on remonte
dans le b sides c'est un des items qui
me font me font penser que la violence
on est dans un cycle où il ya de plus en
plus de violence dans notre pays alors
les solutions parce que c'est bien de
faire un constat mais quelles sont les
solutions
rapidement j'ai entendu toute ma
carrière
les policiers arrêtent et magistrats
relâche ce n'est pas vrai les policiers
arrêtent les magistrats condamnent ces
après la les sanctions sont mal
appliquées voir peu appliquée en france
et vous avez des gens qui devaient avoir
été arrêtés notamment des mineurs 20 x
30 x 40 x sont finalement est passé à
aucun moment par la case
/ or si vous n'avez pas de sanction et
la sanction elle a pas besoin
c'est beccaria le philosophe italien qui
disait ça elle n'a pas besoin d'être
sévère elle a juste besoin d'être
certaine
voilà et que ce soit les amendes les le
travail d'intérêt général
la prison est bien ces choses là n'ont
pas forcément de répressif mais mieux
appliquées c'est ce que vous ne dites
appliquées actuellement et surtout j'en
ai deux sévères les peines
elles ont besoin d'être juste pour que
ce compréhensible mais surtout elles ont
besoin d'être réel on aime si on a
l'impression que ça fait 30 ans que la
droite française 10 a très clairement
même si je pense que si vous comparez la
période où j'étais directeur général on
l'a dit tout à l'heure dans le domaine
de la communication
je n'ai pas réussi tout ce que je
voulais mais honnêtement la session
sécuritaire de la période nicolas
sarkozy était président de la république
était infiniment meilleure que celle qui
est aujourd'hui fait d'une hausse du
nombre de policiers et gendarmes c'est
lui à la droite c'est pas du à droite
c'est dû au contexte je ne sais pas on
va pas rentrer dans des camps des débats
à n'en plus finir
je constate juste que le 2007 à 2012
nous avions nous avons eu en cinq ans un
attentat terroriste tout à la fin du
quinquennat islamistes avec des morts
nous avions encore une diminution des
homicides nous avions une diminution de
la délinquance
aujourd'hui je constate que les choses
sont différentes et pour revenir
là-dessus d'importance le nombre de
policiers quelque chose qui est
important mais fondamentalement ce qui
est important c'est les missions et les
moyens et les moyens c'est bien sûr les
hommes mais ça peut pas être que les
hommes c'est aussi la police devient une
entreprise de plus en plus techniques
c'est aussi les moyens techniques la
police technique et scientifique qui a
permis d'identifier et d'interpeller à
nom de l'assassin de violeurs absolument
considérable eh bien ça ça demande de
l'argent sa demande de l'investissement
et c'est là où il faut aussi le trouver
donc ne résumons pas l'alpha et l'oméga
de la sécurité c'est pas plus de puces
d'homme c'est plus de moyens ça peut
être plus d'hommes mais c'est aussi
quand vous avez des hommes il faut leur
donner les moyens de travailler
les moyens de s'entraîner les moyens de
se former et on va parler des régionales
pour terminer frédéric péchenard nous
avons beaucoup de propositions pour
sortir de la politique de valérie
pécresse qui est celle de l'ancien monde
c'est par ces mots que dorée pulvar
officialisé ce matin dans le parisien sa
candidature aux régionales en
de france qu'en dites vous j'en dis que
valérie pécresse c'est présidente de la
région depuis six ans elle a réussi à
inverser quelque chose l'a fait parce
que c'est une remarquable gestionnaire
la région qui doit être fondamentalement
une collectivité qui investit ce qu'on
demande à la région c'est 2-2 de
construire des lycées de rénover les bus
et les métros et bien que nous sommes
arrivés à la tête de la région
le fonctionnement était plus important
que l'investissement 60% du budget
c'était du fonctionnement et seulement
40% d'investissement aujourd'hui en 2021
et bien les s'est inversée tant que la
région donc c'était mieux gérer si vous
voulez qu'avant ce comme ça en tout cas
que je l'analyse et la série mode
devrait régler ça vaut investir valérie
pécresse politique de l'ancien mundo
c'est absurde si c'est bien quelqu'un
qui représente un ancien amant de chez
moi c'est bien madame pulvar qui est
passé c'est 20 ans de socialisme à paris
voilà l'ancien monde c'est delanoë 20
ans qu'elle en est joliment mais qu'est
ce qu'elle fait elle reprend enfin
excusez moi chacun sait que c'est le
poisson pilote d'anne hidalgo qui a
besoin de gagner la région existe dans
la région
je crois que pour exister au niveau
national mais de la péta salaires en
charge
donc elle a montré qu'on savait que
c'était une excellente gestionnaire
c'est une femme qui est la fois jeune
qui a du talent et qui est d'expérience
et on voit que l'expérience notamment
aux crises sanitaires aujourd'hui passe
quelque chose d'utile et dans la crise
je trouve qu'elle s'est révélée si les
franciliens ont eu des masques c'est
grâce à valérie pécresse
nous nous avons acheté des masques ou
chinois on les a fait venir on nous a
distribué ce que l'état n'a pas été
capable de faire donc je pense que
valérie pécresse est une très bonne
présidente de région
moi j'ai pas choisir nos adversaires
mais je suis d'abord on va attendre de
savoir quand il ya des élections
régionales alors pour l'instant c'était
de la date de jours à voter joint hier
fouetter de cette date il faut la
maintenir en juin oui foulée maintenant
j'espère que ce sera en juin
je comprends qu'on les ait décalé en
mars mais ne rajoutons pas la crise
sanitaire une crise politique une
démocratie c'est simple qu'est ce qui
différencie une démocratie d'un autre
régime comme une dictature ce sont les
élections rien d'autre c'est fondamental
les élections dans une démocratie on
peut pas jouer avec ça or on est capable
de sécuriser les opérations de vote
on l'a fait et puis à la campagne ce
sera différente mais on s'est bien
adapté pour travailler on vous est
adapté pour travailler et bien nous nous
adapterons nous adaptons aujourd'hui
pour faire campagne
on a commencé à femmes quand vous faites
d'une campagne électorale aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que vous ne voyez plus les
gens en vrai vous ne distribue plus de
traces d' allah vous faites des
rencontre zoom vous passez en prime au
sortant est ce que quelque part ça
n'arrange pas valérie pécresse
vous savez c'est pas le sujet c'est pas
ça le sujet c'est pas savoir que si ça
rend sourd ou pas le sujet c'est qu'on a
des règles on a été élus pour six ans en
pas été élu pour sept ans huit ans
devant dix ans quand ça va s'arrêter on
ne sait pas je crois qu'il faut
respecter le temps démocratique il faut
respecter le ce qui est fondamental ce
sont les élections parce que si on
desquels les élections régionales
après pourquoi pas décaler les
présidentielles pendant combien de temps
et si on vit encore cinq ou dix ans avec
le virus après tout qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour les portugais ont voté
et ils ont contrait convenablement élu
leur président de la république
les américains ont voté vous dit-on
façon j'avais aussi moi je souhaite
qu'on va trancher un oui merci beaucoup
merci phase avec les schémas venu nous
voir ce matin on regarde la une de la
république du centre c'est le loiret
sous tension florent merci d'être venus
également
on passe au club des territoires la
mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition
[Musique]